5 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy let's revisit this
issue of nobody pays attention to the
speed limit in the airport connector
tunnels
a viewer who wishes to remain anonymous
right if I go the speed limit in the
tunnels I get honked at ran up on it
have lights flashed at me people are so
aggressive nobody goes 35. I feel like I
have to speed like everyone else for my
own safety
well Anonymous everyone here knows
exactly what you're talking about read
airport spokesman Joe Rachel told us
that before the speed limit was lowered
in 2019 there were 60 crashes in the
tunnels in the first six months of that
year in the first six months of last
year there were 19 crashes
so the conclusion is that even if it
seems like nobody's following the speed
limit it must be having some positive
effect Anonymous thanks for riding stay
safe wherever you go and the rest of us
all need to buckle up and drive
carefully and please put down that phone
if you'd like to join the driving you
crazy conversation it's traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com